fana fancy remake takes some time
explaining all its moving parts so you
may find yourself asking a lot of
questions long before the game is ready
to give you any answers we don't want
you sweating the small stuff instead of
enjoying the game so here's a bunch of
spoiler free heads ups that'll save you
a little bit of stress
[Music]
more mughal metals mole problems around
Midgar you'll often find destructible
boxes you should make a point of
smashing them firstly because they're
puny and pathetic little wooden
constructs that deserve to be crushed
under the might of clouds buster sword
but also because they can sometimes
recover your MP and drop potions or
antidotes more importantly however they
award you with an item called Mughal
medals you saw here Mughal medals from
the outset of the game and you may find
yourself scratching your head trying to
figure out what to do with them
the game doesn't actually tell you what
they're good for straight away but don't
worry a few chapters in you'll meet a
character who will swap Mughal medals
for special items we won't spoil who
this character is because honestly it's
an absolute delight but we will say that
you'll come across the character in a
side quest if you read our review you'll
know that the side quests are well worth
doing for their story and
characterization contributions but if
you needed more convincing this is it so
make sure to do those side quests kupo
hey someone help me with this whether
its guardian forces aliens or Esper's
calling on gods and mythical beings to
fight by your side is a key part of the
final fantasy experience you could do
this in the original Final Fantasy 7 and
you can also do it in the remake however
it can be easy to miss the detail on how
exactly you get these summons especially
since it's very different from the
original and other games in the
franchise the first story is part of the
main story as a character will gift you
a material item that houses the beast
there's absolutely no missing it however
from that point on things get a bit
trickier the next one you'll get is in
Chapter 6 you spot a red material next
to a big fan but it's maddeningly out of
reach don't worry about it you'll get
there eventually continue on with the
main mission and you'll be able to use a
lift to approach a ladder to the left of
those fans and grab the materia just
make sure you don't leave the area
without getting at first the rest of the
summons are tied to a character you meet
shortly after his name is Chad Lee which
according to urban dictionary is a name
given to a made-up boyfriend often used
to deceive others into thinking that you
have a boyfriend so they will stop
questioning you or making fun of you
anyway this strange mashup of Chad and
Bradley presents you with the
opportunity to fight for the summons
Allegiance you may find that the first
summon he pits you against is tricky so
don't stress about trying to defeat it
then and there
you'll see chadley along and you can
take on the fight whenever you're
feeling a little more leveled up further
someone's become available to fight by
completing Charlie's battle challenges
there are two or five summons in the
game and we won't spoil which one
although there is a sixth and a seventh
those are exclusive to a premium version
and pre-orders of the game which is a
bit rubbish if you ask me but wherever
its elemental material gives your
characters our wealth of abilities to
work with in battle these range from the
ability to cast fire ice wind and
lightning spells to manipulate time
create shells to protect allies and
restore their health there's also a few
that will grant you incredibly useful
benefits that may not be initially clear
this is because they require a very
specific setup before they actually take
effect the biggest one of these is
elemental which will make it hurt much
less when the enemy tries to set your
apt on fire tries to freeze you to death
or pull some other magical nonsense to
put an end to your adventure weapons and
armor features sockets that you place
materia into and there are two variants
of sockets there's a single isolated
sake
and then there's joint ones if you get a
piece of armor with a joint socket and
you put an elemental material in there
the armor will give you resistance for
the type of material you attach to the
second slot so for example if you have
one slot with elemental and it's
attached to another slot with fire
equipped anytime the enemy tries to set
you ablaze the damage taken from the
fire attack will be halved as the game
progresses enemies become very
aggressive and can bust out high damage
spells so it's essential to notice
alternatively if you use elemental in a
joint slot on your weapon your attack
will be imbued with that element the
magnifying material works in the same
way except instead of granting you
resistance it costs the attach spell to
multiple targets so if you have
magnified attach to a healing materia it
will kill multiple characters instead of
just one it also works the same way for
offensive spells but it's important to
note that the primary target receives
the bulk of the damage and those around
that target get reduced damage again
this is super useful but you only really
learn this information through a bit of
experimentation stopping power like the
last few mainline entries in the series
Final Fantasy 7 remake is a far more
active and dynamic game when
comes to combat unlike the old days when
characters were rooted in position and
would be forced to watch in horror as
the enemy unleashed ridiculous attacks
and killed their friends around them
characters in the remake can actually
run rings around their enemies if they
choose to however that also means that
the hit and miss system is a little more
dynamic although the remake doesn't
actually make a big deal about it opting
to let you learn through experience
instead it's actually really easy to
fire off a spell and completely with it
timing is key in the remakes combat
model so you need to watch your enemies
closely and use spells when they aren't
wildly darting around the battlefield so
that you can be sure it'll travel and
land properly another major
consideration that will force you to be
careful with the timing of attacks is
that an enemy can interrupt you if
you're casting a spell and the start up
animation is long your opponent could
fire off a quicker attack and stuff
whatever you are trying to do given that
you're spending precious resources to
use these abilities getting marked off
like this will hurt your HP and your ego
even worse is if you poorly time one of
T foe specials or clouds limit break and
the enemy is just out of reach in which
case watching them nonchalantly walk
away from your badass super damaging
super cinematic super move will make you
question whether you're cut out for this
mission at all pick your moments counter
point all right time for a few quick
tips these will be simple but they're
crucial to know and they either easily
missed or not properly understood clouds
unique ability is called Punisher mode
which gives him quicker more powerful
attacks but with mobility as the
trade-off the other thing that the
punishment mode allows you to do is
respond to incoming melee attacks with a
counter so if you're facing an enemy
that's getting all up in your extremely
gelled pointy blond hair and trying to
slap you about activate Punisher mode
and start blocking to show them what
happens when you try to mess with a
former soldier that has pencil-thin arms
but can still haul around a sword the
size of a campervan like I give a [ __ ]
in the eye of the storm eros unique
ability is called Tempest she finds a
crystal at her target that can be
charged up for a more powerful effect
however it's pretty tricky to use as it
comes with some situational applications
this is because the crystal actually
takes a bit of time to do its thing
after air sends it out when you hit
triangle the crystal travels to the
target point and if it connects will do
a small amount of damage if then takes a
couple of seconds to build some power
and explodes dishing out damage to
whoever and whatever is hanging around
it's more of an area of effect spell
than a direct attack so you'll need to
plan it carefully when using the longer
you hold triangle down the more powerful
the explosion will be when it happens
the best time to use Tempest is when
you've hit an enemy with a spell that
locks down their movement or they've
been staggered and thus unable to get
away or if they're being absolutely
pummeled by one of your teammates and
can't do anything but take the deadly
crystals to the face you'll want to use
that bad-boy abilities at the start of
the game your party members will have
limited access to weapons however you
will eventually be able to purchase new
ones or find them out in the world each
one has a cool look and can be leveled
up to become a devastating tool of
destruction as well as bolster your
character's core attributes another
major addition each weapon offers is a
new combat ability every weapon has a
special action that you can execute when
it's equipped however if you look at it
on the weapons leg menu you'll notice
there's a little bar that shows your
proficiency in its special action as you
put the weapon to use that bar will fill
and eventually the associate character
will gain that ability which can be used
wherever you have the weapon equipped or
not that proficiency bar fills up quite
slowly but if you pay attention to the
little bit of text underneath the bar
it'll tell you how you can speed the
process up trust me when I say it's
worth spending a bit of time grinding
whenever you get a new weapon so you can
max out the proficiency bar as quickly
as possible you want to do it with
random enemy mobs that you're familiar
with as you'll need to switch to
specific characters you're working on to
fulfil the objective and it's easier if
you know there won't be any surprises
some weapons are designed to present a
different style of play for the
Associated user and this style may not
vibe with the way you want to play them
so it's best to earn your proficiency in
low stakes bowels you don't want to be
facing a boss with weapons that don't
let you
your characters the way you expect them
out to be chapter select as previously
mentioned this article and in the Final
Fantasy remake review you should be
doing all the side quests you can they
enhance the story and can often give you
valuable items however if you rather
focus on getting the main campaign
finished and don't want to miss out on
anything
you'll be happy to hear that you can
come back and tie up loose ends Final
Fantasy 7 remake has a new game+ of
sorts it's actually a chapter select
that pops up after you've complete the
story and lets you drop in and out of
different chapters while keeping your
experience items and loadouts
the thing to know is that you'll start
at the very beginning of the chapter and
you'll need to complete the chapter to
retain the progress you made within it
so you may need to spend a bit of time
replaying chunks of the game to get to
the bit you want another lesson for life
on the ground floor there you have it a
few essential tips that Final Fantasy 7
doesn't tell you upfront hopefully you
haven't been stressed out by any of this
and if you were don't worry it's all
good you can enjoy the game now make
sure to watch our Final Fantasy 7 remake
video review here on YouTube and if you
have more tips let us know in the
comments below or hit me up on Twitter
at 2 more H
[Music]
you